After decades of limiting families
to
just one child China
has a new message for couples.
Please have another baby.
Why the change of heart.
In short China is aging
and losing its working population.
Although China changed its rules in
to allow couples to have as many as
two children.
That hasn't convinced enough parents
to have more than one high living
costs. Long work hours
and surging child care expenses
means that many couples feel that
they can only
afford to have one child
or even none.
On top of that a study found that 33
percent of women had their pay cut
after
giving birth
and 36 percent were demoted.
If they want to reverse the
demographic
trends that they're
currently facing they will not only
have to deal
with the cost of having a child
they'll also be fighting against
demographic
and social trends in which people
are having
fewer and fewer children.
To counter that trend the Government
is
considering lifting all limits on
the
number of children a family can have
otherwise by 2040
one quarter of the world's most
populous
country will be 65
or older which threatens an
economic boom that's been built on a
vast
labor supply.
Countries don't usually become Great
Powers
when they're old
and graying they become Great Powers
when they're young and vigorous.
And if Xi Jinping wants to complete
that transition he may
need to build a younger country
that can pull it off.
How did we get here
after the creation of the People's
Republic of
China in 1949.
The government train tens of
thousands
of quote barefoot doctors
to bring healthcare to poor
and rural areas.
The result. Mortality rates
plummeted
and the population growth rates
skyrocketed.
By the 1970s China was
facing food
and housing shortages.
In 1979 its leader
Deng Xiaoping decided to
limit most couples to just one
child.
And it worked.
The average births per woman dropped
to
less than 2.
However there was a social
consequence
to this the traditional preference
among Chinese parents for sons
caused many parents to abort female
fetuses.
The imbalance grew to the point
where there were
120 men for every
100 women.
Over time women became very picky
about possible husbands.
Some rural men began to buy wives
from human traffickers.
In early 2018 authorities
rescued 17 Vietnamese women
and arrested a gang of 60
traffickers
who had been selling women in China.
The change to allow two children was
meant
to fix the nation's demographic
problems.
But after an initial spike in the
birth
rate in 2016 the 2017
numbers didn't appear to be as
large.
The indications are that people
won't be
rushing out to have kids they may
see a temporary
bump in the number of children.
But whether that will be a lasting
change
that will affect China's demographic
trajectory seems very much in doubt.